my name is Michael McMenamin and the
latest book my son Patrick and I have
written is the Gemini agenda my name is
Patrick McMenamin and I am the better
looking co-author of our woodson
Churchill filler series one reviewer
called a Weston Churchill meets Indiana
Jones we'd like to use little known
historical facts as a backdrop for our
adventure stories people don't realize
or remember that democracy was in peril
in the nineteen thirties it was thought
to be a thing of the past fascism Nazism
communism was thought to be the wave of
the future and so we picked the air in
nineteen twenty nine to nineteen
thirty-nine to correspond to the time of
Winston Churchill's wilderness years
when he was out of power out of office
and a lone voice in the wilderness
warning against the rise of Nazi Germany
and other totalitarian states but I
think there he's represented a moment in
history when things filter not a lot
worse for all of us and so it's a
fascinating period to sort of start any
kind of adventure story and let's be
honest I mean Churchill also was just
more fun than anybody else in the 1930s
I mean he drank and smoked cigars he had
better one-liners than anybody else so
what's not to like he viewed politics on
a spectrum of liberty and freedom at one
end and authoritarian totalitarianism at
the other and he recognized that both
communism and Nazism were a threat he
simply saw Nazism as the greater threat
the more revolutionary movement joe
stalin didn't excite the masses adolf
hitler did adolf hitler had a real
movement behind him Joe Stalin had the
Red Army our protagonist is Bourke
Cockran jr. the fictional son of Cochran
who was childless Bourke Cockran senior
as we call them was in fact the
political and economic mentor of Winston
Churchill and when creating a
protagonist for the Winston Churchill
thrillers we wanted someone who had a
natural relationship to Churchill and
who better than the son of Churchill's
own political mentor by choosing as a
protagonist the son of a classical
liberal free trader like Bourke Cockran
we created a protagonist that reflected
our own views and therefore as he goes
through our books will have many of the
same reactions to the issues of the day
the
after can I would yeah and I think it's
part of the fun part about being having
a chance to write historical novels is
that libertarians don't have a lot of
historical heroes to cheer for and this
guy actually existed it's amazing to me
to think about there was actually
American politician that was libertarian
in almost every sense of the word and
unfortunate have any children but we
created one and we've given him an
Indiana Jones type of adventures this
start out is my dad's concept you had
thought about this I've heard about this
when I was in high school and I read the
first rap and I was in college and I
started getting involved in editing it
and trying to cut it down eventually I
was writing entire new chapters and we
found we actually had fun doing it there
is one awkward part in in writing a book
with your father there are several sex
scenes in our books and there's nothing
much more awkward than editing your own
father sex scenes so but we're still
friends
you